c'est vrai que la ja game of talent
visuel suspecte good things heures
arnaud ducret dans tous ses états
cédric et voilà il ya erreur en haut du
crédit d'adams ya
eric balat cccc comme c'est comme toi
avec lui est restée
dans la spirale de l'échec
quand ça veut pas ça veut pas ça veut
pas ça veut pas alors hier il y avait
donc
d'affaires global tant les minoritaires
de laval ministère navale ce qu'il a
regardé
à moitié pourquoi ça n'a pas marché est
ce que vous savez moi je me suis
demandée c'est parce qu'on connaît
peut-être trop l'histoire il a également
parlé d'aller au centre au côté des
filles c'est ça c'est trop alors on va
dire qu'on a des éclairs mais
ce serait bien non on la réclame sur les
fictions qu'il se plante son maître ne
pouvait pas mettre d'extraits ça coûte
trop cher
ne mettez pas d'extraire
on va raconter tout ça c'est beaucoup
mieux voilà il paraît que l'on peut
permettre d'extraire a coûté in blood
c'est une connerie parce qu'en plus ce
nom mais savait pourquoi ça n'a pas
marché parce que c'était mauvais non
michèle bernier juifs ou des poèmes et
justement c'est ça le problème à quoi
qu'on savait pas si c'était un film un
documentaire ça se veut docu fiction et
c'est n'importe quoi on ne sait pas ce
qu'on regarde je trouve que c'était mal
joué daval johnatan d'aval l'acteur on
n'y croit pas du tout donc en fait on
est trop loin de l'arrivée c'était bien
mieux le documentaire après mais c'était
trop tard c'était franchement un échec
annoncé non plus cette affaire on la
connaît par coeur il n'y avait rien de
nouveau franchement nul belle bagarre
dôme était malhonnête intellectuellement
parce qu'elle tombait pas un
docu-fiction c'était une fiction sur les
acteurs au climat demande est un
téléfilm en well as tu vois pas ce que
ça va marcher mais je pense que ce que
tu en penses où les raisons il est où il
est mal
dans la vie de tous les jours la met
dedans ça là tout
est normal qu'on en dit que le problème
des idées reste et qui part tout schuss
et à partir du moment où il a demandé de
défoncer une défense sans discernement
des français qui m'a demandé j'ai foncé
mais qui m'a demandé des français 6 est
comme ça l'excusé j'adore mais chez le
père michel barnier dans d'autres
elle est excellent c'est la première
fois que je suis aussi près de toi frère
je comprends pourquoi les janvier
extremis
des prêts intra-groupe je comprends
pourquoi isabelle daniel moreau va toi
dans ton pendant deux ans mais a priori
je te le dis toi tdg pas où tu aimais
royaume est en train de manger et les
potes me desservait chauny non c'est un
truc de fou je me trouve que les
comédiens sont exceptionnels celui qui
joue de manhattan damas il est
incroyable la mise en scène est tout à
fait correct en fait le problème c'est
que juste les gens n'ont pas envie de
voir ça maintenant c'est trop près
d'auxerre on l'a beaucoup trop décrypté
sur les médias récemment c'était sur
toutes les chaînes d'info en flux tendu
et donc il y avait passé les deux
navires ont pas de second et d'annoncer
un nouveau savamment sa mère en revanche
il faut quand même dire qu'il est très
bon acteur tout le monde et il est très
bon dedans et s'était très bien passée
mais il coule
comme on l'a dit c'est trop frais c'est
trop pressé violente et la famille t'es
pas d'accord trois races assez anxiogène
on est déjà dans un paquet de merde t'es
rien si en plus vous allez voir cette
histoire qui est terrible qui n'est pas
vraiment élucidé encore pas un paquet de
merde
prison
mais on n'a pas retrouvé là il a raison
voyons sais pas s'il avait un complice
sebbar
convocation c'est pas fini des enfants
il ya des interrogations oui ni non
beaucoup trop anxiogène ya des gens qui
accusait le téléfilm déjà avant la
diffusion de ce que ça faisait déjà une
polémique avait un gros bad buzz qu'ils
accusaient de tf1 de faire de l'argent
sur une affaire encore chaude qui a
brisé les vies des familles voilà je
trouve que tf1 il s'enflamme sur les
fictions parce qu'ils ont fait quelques
fictions qui ont très très bien marché
du coup ils ont commandé énormément il
ça marche pas tout le temps et d'une
manière générale je trouve que tf1 n'a
plus l'exigence qu'ils avaient il ya
encore dix ans en prime ils mettent des
trucs qui pourrait passer sur la tnt y
font des documentaires
touristes empruntent ce genre et ils ont
fait un doc / dollar us à passer sur tf1
c'est pourtant et voilà c'est ça les
immersions en parlant anglais voilà donc
en terme de budget ils ont ils ont
baissé les prix la baisse l'audience
globale parce que sur tf1 c'est plus
l'événement comme c'était à 10 ans voit
là mais c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi qu'ils
disent peut-être le lundi soir et à
l'amour est dans le pré en face on en
parlait dans un instant de 5,6 un énorme
carton c'est je pense d'ailleurs on va
se poser la question je pense que
l'amour est dans le pré et le format le
plus fort actuellement en télévision
alors voilà les audiences l'amour est
dans le pré numéro 4,3 millions et la
montagne fleurira c'est un truc voilà
sur voilà sur des gars qui font race qui
le mystère navale il y avait américaine
sniper j'adore ce film incroyable sur
france 3 qui a plutôt bien marché
d'ailleurs pour un film en cours sur
france 3 revient mais si tu me cyrille
frantz toi et tu vois américaine snipers
sur france 3 tu le dis si ces battues
lors amy tu aurais mis le même film sur
france 2 16 ghz et plus et l'art du
derrière une folle histoire de fesses
saiban la méditation cransac et en plus
la ville et en plus ça bien c'est super
a tardé sa tombe et naïm gioria
s'attachant les deux ce qui se passe à
la maison
achetée sur c'est sûr mais là c'est la
première fois qu'elle regarde france 5 à
la
tient l'arrière d'une voiture
mais c'est vrai c'est un truc de fou il
veut parler on sait pas il veut son
livre sont brouillées quelqu'un on sait
pas qui est un complément à philippe
satellite je vous adore
[Applaudissements]
l'amour est dans le pré mais j'adore moi
aussi j'adore franchement c'est
formidable avant mais moitié que je
tombe dessus mais je reste c'est d'abord
aller elle et elle et elle fait ça très
bien karine elle et elle est très proche
des gens il ya quelque chose de très
réjouissant
moi j'aime bien alors tu peux aimer qui
tu veux ici c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas de
mal de gens qui sont pas comme débat
corps en tout cas je tard il me semble
qu'elle incarne très bien ça et que et
que et que en paix ses frais voilà c'est
que
contrairement à ce qu'on pense à ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure sur la sphère
d'aval il ya il exact pendant contraire
là il ya quelque chose me lie d'humains
c'est un énorme carton vous feriez
d'aidé ont fait un point de leur
proposer des fictions sur tf1 oui oui
oui moi j'ai bien sûr que j'en ferais
j'avais j'avoue j'aime beaucoup ça je
vois là je n'ai pas vu donc je ne
pourrais pas en parler mais oui bien sûr
c'est le hasard a bien sûr carton
balthazar balthazar c'est un carton
partout et pas ça cartonne en france que
ce soit on va serrer qui va sortir
espère aussi que c'est la carte six mois
la maison d'en face chez m6 ouais retire
liévin septembre c'est un unitaire ou
bien y en a plusieurs et six épisodes 6
épisodes la maison d'en face c'est quoi
ce genre à des problèmes de voisinage
mes voisines les couples en face et
faire un bébé et mon couple et pratiquer
l'échangisme
[Applaudissements]
jacques pénalise regardez
sur les quelque chose c'était une
brocante à la fée du 3 15
donc ça va exciter ameling frétille à
des histoires de fait avait regardé les
couples échangistes benhaim elle est
enfin la fin mais c'est devenu banal
email frétille à sémalens mais je te le
jure à la mer franchement elle fait plus
le wet les chercheurs
comme ça alors laissé à la maison d'en
face pas je vais regarder j'ai regardé
ça va marcher ça ça va rejeter fiction
sur m6 mais c'est vrai que malabo après
voilà il ya plein de trucs n'ont pas
marché on voulait en parler on a on a
parlé d' d'alcy hier c'est vrai il ya
visuel suspecte aussi qui avait pas
marché game of talent en plus se
présenter par mon ami jean luc reichmann
bako que j'aime mais voilà il pas la
goutte singer génère plus tirer à la il
ya arnaud ducret voilà bah voila voila
quoi qui sien c'était quoi vous de
single good singers et les bons
chanteurs
ne peut pas raconter d'histoires et puis
à vise le coeur aussi qui a pas marché
la série vise le coeur la semaine
dernière mais c'était pendant que
pendant la disparition de la reine
d'angleterre